[Musique] étrangère
à la fin de la journée, que faites-
vous, restez-vous allongé et mourez ou essayez-vous
comme n'importe quel être humain, animal ou combattez-vous pour
survivre et cette fois, la survie se
connecte illégalement au réseau,
mais comme je l'ai dit  dans de nombreuses réunions où
nous sommes prêts, nous sommes vraiment prêts à
payer pour cette électricité,
l'électricité est si faible que Dieu merci, nous
pompons même le pudding à l'oxygène et
nous devons ensuite les arrêter à l'hôpital,
pensez-vous que c'est gratuit en tant qu'êtres humains
sous les
déconnexions qui  affecter une communauté plus large,
c'est quelque chose que la ville
du Cap ne peut pas tolérer, cela coûte
très cher, bien sûr, vous
savez, les connexions illégales
avant le deuxième trimestre, je veux dire, nous avons dépensé
quatre millions de rands, je veux dire et c'est
beaucoup d'argent.
Musique]
[Musique]